for over five decades the U.S government
ran a mass surveillance program on
American citizens in Puerto Rico they
spied on anyone who advocated for Puerto
Rico's independence from the United
States anyone who had the wrong
political ideas the leaders of this
movement were put on around-the-clock
surveillance by the FBI and everyone
deemed to be associated with it was
watched and tracked at one point the FBI
director pulled his agents to uncover
people's weaknesses their morals their
criminal records their spouses their
children their family life their
educational qualifications and personal
activities and to track it meticulously
in files tens of thousands of files when
it was all discovered after 50 years of
this program there was 1.8 million pages
of surveillance documents all of this is
just one of several examples of how the
US went to Great Lengths to brutally
repress and control Puerto Rico